[Applaudissements]
le nouvel an le président de gaulle a
reçu par la voix d'une once pontificale
les voeux du corps diplomatique échange
de souhaits officielle qui se fondait
dans l'écho des paroles que présidente
aux tâches et aux difficultés de la
nouvelle année le chef de l'état adressé
aux français pour l'algérie nous voulons
que 1961 soit l'année de la paix
rétablie
afin que les populations puissent
décider librement de leur destin et pour
que naisse l'algérie algérienne
françaises français je vous le demande
donnée aux projets qui vous est soumis
une approbation immense car s'il devait
arriver par malheur que la réponse du
pays fut ou négative ou 1 10 6 en raison
d'une faible majorité ou marqué par
beaucoup d'abstention quelles
conséquences résultera de cette
impuissance et de sept divisions et à
moi même
vous le savez bien quel coût serait
ainsi porté ma pêchant de poursuivre ma
tâche
françaises français aujourd'hui
tous ensemble nous offrons nos voeux à
la france le 8 janvier
nous lui offrirons le oui franc et
massif de notre espoir est de notre foi
cette plaque dévoilée à l'ancienne
entrée de leur collège combien d'élèves
la côtoieront il sans y porter attention
pourtant elle rappelle que dans l'ombre
du tout jeunes tentés au san barbe vient
d'avoir 500 ans un demi millénaire
c'est dire que quelques générations ont
précédé ici les fringants barbistes de
1961 l'acte de fondation date en effet
de 1460 cette année là le plus vieux
collège de paris ouvrait ses portes sur
la montagne sainte geneviève
alors que la récuse à sa plaie encore la
rue aux chiens le temps passa mais la
tour où habite à calvin existe toujours
le décor passa du 18e ou 19e sans trop
de transformation ils connurent ses
cours ce réfectoire ce dortoir
certains élèves devenus célèbres comme
charles péguy qui fut poète et jérôme
tarot qui fut académiciens ils connurent
t-il jaurès bons élèves au bhoutan
élogieux
et paul deschanel cancre sans espoir que
sa lettre de renvoi n'empêcha pas de
devenir président de la république
l'histoire a passé cinq cents ans se
sont donc inscrits aux livres de compte
que nos collèges conserve les révolution
de 1830 puis de 48 ne fut remarqué que
par des consignes et des punitions 1961
les barbistes peuvent rêver à la gloire
de certains de leurs anciens aussi
différents qu'ignace de loyola jean
calvin saint françois xavier
les frères montgolfier gustave fm
et l'on peut imaginer que parmi ces
jeunes visages il y aura peut être un
créateur d'ordre 1ere ziar un inventeur
un constructeur de génie et quoi encore
plus de trains des gares déserte plus de
postes les sacs postaux en attente
[Musique]
plus debout et les ordures envahissant
les rues c'est le spectacle qu'offre
toute la belgique en ce début d'année
tout au plus à bruxelles d'une fraction
de postiers at elle tenté de continuer
le travail sous la protection de la
force publique
le grand meeting ont acclamé la grève
générale dirigée contre le gouvernement
et skins promoteurs de mesures
d'austérité connu sous le nom de loi
unique dont les grévistes ont fait loi
inique anvers comme toutes les grandes
villes a suivi bruxelles des
manifestations se sont déroulées qui
disait un flamand ce que les autres
disent est en français
et les jours passant la grève après pied
partout les manifestations se sont
aggravées on a vu dans les rues de la
capitale dix mille manifestants défilent
et derrière leur second combatif et
transformer parfois leur marche en
désordre
la 11e journée de cette grève illimitée
la première depuis 10 ans a même vu le
sang coulait des blessés un mort et pour
le reste les vestiges habituel des
émeutes
comment se résoudre à la crise dont la
grève n'est que le décor fiévreux toute
l'économie belge est stoppée mines
déserte port vide
les grévistes tiendront-ils le
gouvernement cédera-t-il le roi de
retour ramènera t-il le calme
on attend
[Musique]
c'est une fin d'année dramatique qu'a
connu l'équipage du pétrolier américain
pas une ride coupée en deux par la
tempête dans l'atlantique au large du
cap hatteras alors que l'avant avec ou
les 29 hommes avaient trouvé refuge sur
la partie arrière rester à flot les
hélicoptères du porte-avions valley
forge
depuis les évacuer à l'exception du chef
mécanicien tout un tas rester à bord
l'ultime gardien de l'épave et qui
devaient rentrer avec elle à bon port
pour eux c'était au drame
une fin heureuse mais s'étonne manqué
des officiers rester sur l'avant terre
du corps et biens
au bord de l'oubangui le plus importants
affluents du congo bangui a terminé
l'année 1960 dans un calme qui
n'excluait pas la liesse le chef de
l'état monsieur david dacko qui avait à
ses côtés monsieur louis jacquinot
ministre d'état français à président et
diverses cérémonies
la nouvelle république centrafricaine
célébrer en effet les fêtes de son
indépendance proclamée le 13e depuis
cette date l'ancien oubangui chari est
en effet devenu un état souverain de 617
mille kilomètres carrés
c'est à dire plus grand que la france et
qui compte un million huit cent mille
habitants
bangui la capitale qui a vu se dérouler
une semaine de réjouissances peut être
considéré comme le symbole de l'avenir
modeste poste voici cinquante ans c'est
aujourd'hui une cité de près de 5000
habitants jeunesse qui promet voici
reggane reagan autrement dit une ville
ou plutôt un centre ultramoderne
construit au coeur du désert à 15 100 km
au sud de rang aux portes du tanet
souffre et qui trouve sa justification
dans la série d'expériences nucléaire
dont la troisième vient d'avoir lieu un
nombre respectable de kilomètres
séparent reggane du lieu de l'explosion
là depuis plusieurs jours l'engin était
prêt ou se remet de sa tour dans la
tempe des vents favorables alentours
chaque arme avait disposé du matériel
témoins le génie c'est peu la cavalerie
ses chars et leurs servent un fictif
l'armée de l'air ces avions les uns
protégée par un mur de béton les autres
sans protection et même une fusée
l'infanterie elle avait disposé des
mannequins bien alignées comme il se
doit ou dans la position du tireur
couché des cages étaient réservées à des
animaux cobayes il est maintenant 7h30
le général kir et actionne un bouton
et dans la nuit seul l'oeil de la caméra
est fixe et en face l'éclairer bluey
sens de la troisième banque française
il s'agissait cette fois d'un engin de
faible puissance quelques kilotonnes
précise le communiqué des armées un
nouveau pas vers la miniaturisation de
la bombe à trets lutte nécessaire à la
bande h
premier autorisés à s'approcher de la
zone interdite
les hélicoptères porteurs d'eau compteur
geiger est chargée de vérifier le danger
de radioactivité
après eux les équipes d'observation
pouvaient à leur tour reprendre le
chemin du point d'explosion les divers
témoins placées autour du point zéro et
dont on a vu les étalages avait en effet
des renseignements à fournir sur les
effets immédiats des radiations et sur
leur persistance
[Musique]
les animaux quant à eux était attendu au
bourget lapin tortue cobayes ra
maintenant on va étudier les effets de
la bombe numéro 3 et regan rentrée pour
un temps dans le silence
le prélude au référendum en algérie ce
fut l'arrivée à mers-el-kébir d'une
escadre parti de toulon précautions pour
cet énorme partie qui allait se jouer
service d'ordre pour un cas spécial dans
un rang le calme règnait calme plat
seulement traversé deux patrouilles mais
dont le sens profond se manifester chez
les européens par le refus
[Musique]
oran comme alger votre est non
dans alger la casbah rester calmes mais
si les éléments français refusait le oui
les musulmans observait une réserve
absolu suite des consignes d'abstention
du fln peut-être la population arabe ne
bougea pas de ses ruelles pour aller
voter
tout au plus deux rares électeurs pas
certes ils les portes des bureaux de
vote
[Musique]
dans le bled moins soumis aux manoeuvres
et aux menaces du fln l'ambiance était
tout à fait différent dans ce village de
kabylie la participation musulmane même
féminine se montrait contact et il faut
constater que les campagnes algérienne
vos terres et qu'elle vote r oui
[Musique]
dans le bled oranais même affluence les
consignes du fln n'ont pas produit ici
l'effet obtenu dans les villes puisque
le bled à voter avec moins de 40%
d'abstentions
[Musique]
et
en france le corps électoral a fait son
devoir - largement sans doute qu au
dernier référendum mais plus massivement
que ne le prévoyaient les augures et
derrière les visages des leaders des oui
et des non paul reynaud
jacques duclos
[Musique]
jacques soustelle
guy mollet les français ont apporté leur
bulletin
tout comme eux à colombey les deux
églises le président de la république
est allé lui aussi glissé son bulletin
dans l'urne avec les 185 autres
électeurs de son village détail à
colombes et il y a un nom
[Musique]
toute la nuit le ministère de
l'intérieur a publié les résultats de la
journée dont la leçon devait être tirée
pour les journalistes par le ministre de
l'information monsieur terrenoire en
métropole plus de 75% des votants en
algérie 68 % des votants avaient dit oui
le oui franc et massif demandé par le
général de gaulle pour construire
l'avenir
[Musique]
n'est peut-être pas trop tard pour
parler encore d'elle elle je veux dire
la nuit du nouvel an la voici à londres
d'un trafalgar square et l'on ne
prétendra plus que la vieille angleterre
est impayée rigorisme toute folie est
inconnu et toute licence interdite
alors voici rassurés essai anglais quand
il le faut savent se mouiller
acquise par la force
voici bientôt deux ans l'analyse de la
chine sur le tibet se manifestent chaque
jour par une réorganisation générale
destinée à balayer de fond en comble
l'ancien système la réforme agraire en
est la principale c'est ainsi que les
paysans de la province de notes chaudes
et mika ont été conviés à une remise de
titres de propriété des terres
confisquées à ceux de leurs processeurs
qui ont défendu l'ancien régime
cette réforme a fait aujourd'hui deux
millions huit cent mille me soit près de
deux cent mille hectares de terres et
l'on peut très bien ne pas être d'accord
sur les procédés et les méthodes
il est difficile de considérer sans une
certaine émotion le plaisir de ces
pauvres gens à se sentir devenu
propriétaire
[Musique]
depuis trois semaines la belgique vit
des heures trou liège qui est avec
bruxelles le plus important foyer de
l'agitation a vu se dérouler des
manifestations tantôt calmes comme celle
ci tantôt violente comme celle qui
devait faire 75 blessés dont l'un devait
succomber nonce la capitale du borinage
a été également le théâtre de scènes
dramatiques qui ont eu lieu au cours de
la démonstration de 15000 grévistes du
pays noir
bruxelles aussi a connu des scènes de
violence dans les rues aux magasins
fermés les manifestants ont pris quinze
à vingt mille se sont heurtés à un
service d'ordre sévère charge de
cavaliers sabre au clair accrochages
sans douceur
les manifestants ont été refoulés mais
on a là aussi compter quelques blessés
la grève coûte au pays un milliard de
francs belges par jour
quelle en sera l'issue
édifié sur les quais de la seine à paris
où elle a été inaugurée par le ministre
des travaux publics monsieur robert
buron la nouvelle maison de la
batellerie s'inscrit résolument dans la
ligne nouvelle
[Musique]
et
vaste parallélépipède sur pilotis cet
édifice en partie financé par la caisse
nationale de sécurité sociale offrira
aux bateliers tous les services avec
lesquels il se trouve habituellement en
contact services médico sociaux ou
scolaires aussi bien que services
professionnels postaux et d'affrètement
le tout à portée de la main
[Musique]
c'est dans la ligne nouvelle que ce
inscrits également cette construction
qui a vu le jour à wuppertal en
allemagne et qui réservé à l'usagé
exclusif des automobiles
il s'agit de deux voix superposées en
spirale lune montante l'autre
descendante qui permettent d'accéder aux
étages d'un grand magasin où un parking
est prévu
on peut évidemment se dire qu'un
ascenseur aurait pu faire la faire mais
on peut se dire aussi qu'après avoir
conduit madame à l'état il intéresse
monsieur peut toujours tuer le temps en
continuant à tourner en rond comme dans
une vis sans fin
sur le ring du palais des sports un
boxeur noir un boxer blanc un champion
du monde n'avait moore le boxeur noir un
champion d'europe qui voudrait bien
devenir champion du monde des poids
plume gras sur averti le boxeur plan de
peuples données du vague à l'âme
mauvais départ pour gracieux dans partie
qui reste au tapis pour 8 secondes et de
ne pas très cher de ses chances dans les
fauteuils de rim
c'est mal connaître le boxeur français
qui va opérer un redressement forte et
inattendue
bien sûr ils encaissent encore des coups
mais il martèle lui aussi son adversaire
sous tous les angles à la cadence d'une
mitrailleuse ça doit faire mal tout cela
à preuve c'est le champion du monde qui
perd toute dignité qu'ils aient cru au
début du combat un combat qui reprend de
plus belle après rapide au bout duquel
en fin de compte tous les spectateurs
attendent maintenant le miracle et
pourquoi pas après tout au coup de gong
final pas de miracle certes mais la
quasi certitude que grâce l empire type
devenir champion du monde
davet moore lui même qui a gagné de
justesse au poids en est persuadé
fini les tribunes du stade remplacé par
la façade austère d'une clinique fini
les congratulations dans les vestiaires
après la victoire l'horizon de juste
fontaine l'avant centre de l'équipe de
france de football
ce sont désormais les quatre murs blancs
de la chambre d'hôpital il rejouera au
football mais campe dans huit mois
disent les médecins
en attendant la jambe gauche qui a déjà
marqué tant de bus ankylose dans le
plâtre
match de la vérité pour l'équipe de
france de rugby maillot blanc qu'une
blanche devant les échos c'est une
vérité qui n'est peut-être pas bonne à
dire cette offensive de l'équipe de
france de 30 personnes tout cela est
désordonné mal conçu et pour tout dire
inquiétant pour l'avenir
bien sûr il ya les coups de pied d' al
balah des gens qui font mouche mais on
ne joue pas au rugby qu'avec ses pieds
[Applaudissements]
les écossais en font la démonstration
voici comment on cartonne un adversaire
selon les plus pure tradition
il faut que tout le monde y passe
remp étriqué cette attaque française des
trois quarts sont encore les uns sur les
autres c'est presque injuste il suffit
encore d'un simple coup de pied d'al
banna des jo pour ajouter trois points
de plus au tableau d'affichage c'est au
moment où personne n'y croit plus que
les attaquants français commence à
s'amuser un peu encore faut-il qu'il
soit aidé par leur troisième ligne la
balle vole de mains mais c'est
finalement crauste le troisième ligne
aile qui donne l'essai à ces trois
transformations d'alvalade et joe les
français gagnent par 11 à 0
c'est beaucoup trop cher pour les
écossais
la belgique a vécu sa quatrième semaine
de grève marquée comme à hoboken près
d'anvers de défilés et de manifestations
contre la loi unique adoptée par la
chambre celle ci conserve des ennemis
déterminés
parmi eux les élus socialistes wallons
hauteur de l'adresse au roi qui met en
cause les institutions unitaire de la
belgique à mieux surtout andré renard le
leader syndicaliste wallon qui prêche
toujours la continuation de la grève
dans les centres où la troupe a relayé
la police pour la protection des usines
un allègement c'est pourtant manifesté
si les provinces de liège et du hainaut
demeure installé dans la grève les
fédérations anversoise et gantoise ont
ordonné la reprise du travail et à liège
même pour la première fois depuis trois
semaines les trams ont recommencé à
circuler
on
à paris en présence du général de gaulle
la place dauphine a changé de nom elle
portera désormais celui du maréchal de
france de lattre de tassigny qui n'est
que juste dira le président de la
république que paris graves sur ses murs
le nom du maréchal de l'afld
c'est à dire celui d'un soldat d'un chef
d'un homme qui fut grande quand c'était
difficile
701 scellage aujourd'hui de la
cathédrale de chartres qui ne la connaît
en france ou ailleurs son histoire elle
se raconte tout au long des enluminures
du temps et gravures des siècles
suivants dans ses tableaux temps où tout
un monde se dévoile le monde du miracle
de chartres le monde des 10000
rassembleur de la pierre de dieu comme
les nomme à peggy dont le nom de ce
peuple c'est près de chartes car en ce
temps là pour rebâtir l'église détruite
par un incendie
un peuple entier se mit à l'ouvragé
trente années durant le ciel de la
beauce pu voir monter à 6 par assises
les colonnes et les statuts qui
accompagne chaque étage le plus pauvre
apporta sa pierre et des milliers de
tailleur de maçon de charpentier et
d'imagiers dessinèrent sous les ordres
d'un architecte audacieuse est génial
dans le nom est resté inconnu
l'énorme vaisseau qui devait apparaître
dans sa blancheur de nouveautés à la fin
de l'an mille deux cent soixante
[Musique]
on avait vu des fidèles s'atteler au
chariot les riches comme les pauvres
servir de compagnon aux hommes de métier
on avait vu dans cet élan général qui
fut peut-être l'un des grands instants
nationaux les flèches monte plus haut
que tous les édifices existants pour
être ce symbole touchant et insensé de
ce que peut faire la fois d'un peuple
il faut revenir à payer tour de david
voici votre tour beauceronne c'est les
piles plus dure qui soit jamais monté
vers un ciel de clémence et de sérénité
[Applaudissements]
qu'un chat puisse être le client du
festival mondial des oiseaux rien à cela
que deux parfaitement logique
les chats aiment les oiseaux et si nous
nous suivons le boeuf le chat lui suit
son idée s'il est sensible aux champs
des canaries il préférait lié amitié
avec quelqu'un de plus consistant et
dans cette exposition on a 1000 toi qu'à
la hausse et toucan de toutes sortes
levy restent rébus érotisée pour les uns
and fast idée petit regret cela
convainque et ses leaders pour les
autres c'est sa bru pour année d'afrique
australe
jali n'effarouche est très bon quand ça
tire qui nonobstant anneaux à faire peur
tiennent plutôt de la pintade et de la
perdrix
sympathique mais trop vert sans doute un
touché des flamands mais ces messieurs à
gros becs habite vraiment trop on finira
chez les perroquets mais qu'il est mal
commode de s'inviter chez d'aussi fichu
caractère
[Musique]
vous êtes à des occupations disons plus
élevé qu'on a convié hector hector est
un charmant rappelant que les
spécialistes français destinées aux
voyages dans l'espace
mais on n'est pas un rat de l'espace
comme ça pour l'accomplissement de sa
haute mission hector a été dotée d'une
combinaison spéciale qui se fixe par des
ressorts abati métalliques dans cet
appareil
hector s'est vu confier aux délices de
l'entraînement spatiale et en
particulier à ceux de la centrifugeuse
doit donner un avant-goût du vol sans
pesanteur
avec hector six autres races en prennent
au centre d'études et de recherches de
la médecine astronautique et comme lui
ils pourront le jour j avoir l'honneur
de prendre place dans l'habitacle de la
fusée véronique et de faire depuis la
base d'un aggir près de colomb béchar le
bord de 200 km dans l'espace
aux etats unis ce sont des chimpanzés
qui se préparent au grand voyage par une
visite médicale très serré comme on voit
mais si ceux qui auront l'honneur
d'ouvrir à l'homme la voix du cosmos
doivent avoir bon pied bon oeil
on leur demande aussi autre chose que
d'être des passagers inerte aussi
cultive-t-on leur intellect ou du moins
leurs réflexes dans leur habitacle
ils devront en effet savoir obtenir eux
mêmes leur nourriture donc actionné la
bonne manette
hum hum
dans un monde sans pesanteur ils devront
savoir aspirer leur boisson favorite
on ne peut tout de même pas espérer que
de bons moments dans l'espace et les
futurs astronautes américains ont dû
aussi s'habituer au terrible
accélération du lancement
à quand le grand départ
[Musique]
on n'arrête pas le progrès et le progrès
donne raison aux automobilistes pressés
contre la voiture à bras qui se traîne
c'est pourquoi désormais nous ne verrons
sans doute plus le petit déménageurs on
envoyait encore quelques-uns transporté
ses pénates d'un bout à l'autre de paris
le moteur vient de marquer un nouveau
point un décret va étendre à toute la
capitale l'interdiction aux voitures à
bras de circuler
on aurait pu évidemment envisager
d'autres solutions moins radicales
rendre obligatoire le port des patins à
roulettes par exemple ce qui eût permis
d'aller plus vite ou bien encore obligé
les usagers des voitures abraham unir
leurs véhicules d'un quelconque système
de démultiplication tel celui de
l'inventeur bien connu claude b cogner
qui a permis lui aussi d'accélérer le
mouvement
et ces solutions semble-t-il ont dû être
écartés à cause des excès de vitesse due
à de possibles pertes du contrôle
et ce temps on a choisi l'interdiction
excellent début des skieurs français
dans les grandes compétitions
internationales de sports d'hiver
ce sont les skieuses qui ont ouvert le
bal des restes d'une grande
triomphatrice du slalom spécial de
grindelwald se classe quatrième de la
descente un peu essoufflée mais
souriante tout de même perdu à wengen
succès beaucoup plus éclatant encore des
skieurs français charles bozon sans
prendre de risques dans un style très
cool et termine 3e du slalom d'une place
au bar org
[Musique]
pas mal du tout pour un début de saison
voici guy périllat également dans le
slalom
perrillat se contente de glisser en
souplesse ce n'est pas un spécialiste
ce qu'il préfère par dessus tout c'est
la vitesse pour lui une seule épreuve
importante la descente il se confronte
un bon classement au slalom
le vainqueur du slalom c'est
l'autrichien schuyler qui s'efforce de
marcher sur les traces de toni sailer il
a beaucoup moins d en se pendant
la descente du lauberhorn c'est le
triomphe de guy perry a lancé comme un
bolide sur des rails périllat plonge
vers l'arrivée beaucoup d'audace de la
virtuosité de l'élégance dans le geste
voilà ce qu'il faut pour gagner une
grande épreuve internationale et
pourrait être considéré comme le
meilleur skieur de tous les temps on
connaissait leur a trouvé son successeur
sans aucun doute
ce n'est pas le jour j mais le jour cap
qu'akon kennedy coiffé d'un
haut-de-forme comme le veut le protocole
john fitzgerald kennedy 35e président
des états unis a solennellement pris ses
fonctions
[Applaudissements]
après l'hymne national chanté par marian
anderson le plus jeune président que les
états unis aient jamais élu a prêté le
serment traditionnel sur la bi
après avoir reçu les félicitations de
son concurrent dixon et de son
prédécesseur le général eisenhower
le nouvel hôte de la maison blanche a
prononcé son premier discours officiel
nous ne devons jamais négocié de la peur
mais nous ne devons jamais avoir peur de
négocier telle est la première formule
du président kennedy formule qui a
aujourd'hui dans le monde entier un
retentissement que n'ont pas couvert les
fanfares et les applaudissements du
défilé final défilé digne en tout de
cette prestigieuse inauguration c'est le
mot qu'on emploie outre atlantique et
qui met là comme il se doit la ba les
troupes les drapeaux les fausses indien
les classiques majorettes et même un
bison
bienvenue à kennedy
texas tower numéro 4 n'existe plus la
tempête l'a englouti avec ses 28 ans
c'était l'un de ces îlots artificiels
édifié comme autant d'observatoire à
danser de la défense américaine ces
radars pouvant détecter une attaque
une minute avant ceux du continent une
minute qui compte
le porte-avions wasps et ses
hélicoptères ont patrouillé en vain les
28 hommes ont péri corps et biens avec
1961 l'aviation commerciale est entré de
plain-pied si l'on peut dire dans l'ère
du gept les distances se sont abolis ou
presque puisque new york n'est plus qu'à
8 heures de paris les capitales se sont
rapprochés paris moscou
4h35
et le réseau d'air france le plus long
du monde avec ses 325 1000 km est devenu
le plus rapide avec son parc d'avions à
réaction
17 boeing et 24 carats belle une flotte
puissante basée sur l'unité de moyens 17
boeing
c'est une capacité simultanée de deux
mille cent soixante seize passagers à
destination des quatre coins du globe et
pour lesquels 900 km se réduisent à une
heure
24 caravanes c'est la possibilité de
transporter simultanément 1824 passagers
sur les moyennes distances environnent
1h15
on peut rêver toutes les villes du monde
à portée de la main
le verglas s'est tant cette saison
l'ennemi le plus terrible parce que le
plus secret le plus imprévus en un mot
le plus traître
bien sûr les ponts et chaussées ne sont
pas désarmés
chaque soir les camions emplis de sable
et de sel sont prêts à intervenir
[Musique]
oh
mieux au long de l'autoroute on
expérimente des appareils détecteurs de
verglas qui donne la large
[Musique]
aloïs ipc police à l'aide de près
la larme va déclencher deux opérations
celle d'abord qui incombe à la police
les motards vont reconnaître les plaques
de verre plein en formation et en faire
connaître l'importance au service des
ponts et chaussées
tous
la plaque de verglas commence après le
port de la location d'orly environ à 50
mètres mais les moteurs vont aussi
veiller à la sécurité des automobilistes
en attendant le déroulement de la
seconde opération le sablage de la zone
dangereuse par les camions des ponts et
chaussées sans doute on ne peut songer
encore adopté toutes les routes d'un tel
dispositif alors automobilistes écouter
les conseils de votre radio de bord
circulation difficile et même dangereuse
sur la nationale aux 388 aux environs de
saint rémy
un détour peut vous éviter bien des
ennuis
lorsque le temps risque d'être propice
au verglas dit vous aussi qu'une vitesse
réduite peut vous éviter de sérieux
déboires commencé à être prudent c'est
votre meilleure arme et ne pensez pas
que cela ne peut pas vous arriver à vous
on en a vu d'eau
certains esprits inventifs se sont
penchés sur ce problème du verglas
bien entendu ils n'ont pas tardé à
trouver un remède le remède
le voici une bande de caoutchouc d'un
diamètre supérieur à celui du pneu et
maintenir relativement lâche par une
armature la bande de caoutchouc adhère
au sol glissant le pneu rôle sur la
bande et tour est joué le système de la
chimie peut-être en belgique l'invention
obéit au souci du moindre effort et le
siège se tente de lui même au conducteur
plus besoin de s'échiner à manoeuvrer
la voiture se sort elle même du
stationnement par translation latéral et
ça n'est pas tout le coffre dissimule
tout un appareillage sans aucun doute
électronique
et voici la voiture qu'on a plus besoin
de se donner le mal de conduire pour la
raison très simple qu elle se conduit
toute seule
encore un miracle du radar l'antenne
détecte les obstacles et les freins
femme reste la voiture sans chauffeur
enfin
[Musique]
éprouvette bébé artificiel on n'en est
pas encore tout à fait là mais le
professeur petrucci et son équipe de
bologne ont peut-être par leurs travaux
ont ouvert la voie en obtenant pendant
29 jours le développement d'un embryon
humain en laboratoire les biologistes
bologne et ont pu enregistrer de bout en
bout cette expérience en adaptant à
leurs microscopes un appareil de prise
de vue cinématographique il dispose
aujourd'hui d'un film pour étudier les
phases du processus de la naissance de
l'homme et en particulier l'instant de
la fécondation
on va voir sur l'écran à gauche neuville
pénétrer par le spermatozoïde
[Musique]
en réussissant à prolonger le
développement de neuf féconder pendant
neuf jours le professeur petrucci a
marqué sans aucun doute un jalon
important sur le chemin de la
connaissance
deuxième grande épreuve internationale
de la saison de ski à kitzbühel en
autriche avec le hahnenkamm le jeune
autrichien henning avec l'audace de ses
20 ans se joue de toutes les difficultés
du ca l'homme et par la même occasion de
ses adversaires puisqu'il remporte
l'épreuve devant le français guy
périllat sperian prend pas trop de
risque il sait qu'il est le champion
numéro un pour lui un seul objectif la
première place du combiné pour convient
à tous qu'il est un skieur contre
le français bozon lui c'est le styliste
il se contente d'une démonstration
souplesse qui lui assure cependant la 8e
place du slalom ce qui aurait quand même
pu lui valoir un joli coup de chapeau
mais la vérité du skieur ne s'exprime
que par la vitesse dans cette spécialité
guy périllat est imbattable c'est le
super champion
avant l'épreuve on le sait qu'il va
gagner c'est décourageant pour ses
adversaires textile
toni sailer l'ancien champion olympique
on est tous rêveur l'autrichien dunning
à pau forcé tant qu'il le peut il est
bien obligé de s'incliner
guy périllat est incontestablement le
meilleur skieur de la saison
[Musique]